pour limiter la hausse à 4 % le
gouvernement a actionné deux leviers le
premier c'est une baisse de la fiscalité
8 milliards d'euros de taxe sur
l'électricité en moins et le second
levier c'est la reine l'accès régulé à
l'électricité nucléaire historique
il s'agit d'un dispositif qui comptera
edf à vendre à prix cassé son
électricité à des concurrents pour que
ceux ci puissent rester compétitif eh
oui si vous êtes un client d'un
fournisseur d'électricité autres que des
f sachez que si votre facture est ce
qu'elle est c'est grâce à la reine et
surtout à l'europe mais on y reviendra
habituellement l'entreprise leur cèdent
environ un quart de sa production les
concurrents comme total direct energie
ce we ou angie revendre cette énergie à
leurs clients en se fournissant
également sur le marché européen de
l'électricité
sauf que voilà fin d'année dernière
patatras crise russo ukrainienne est
tension sur le gaz font bondir les prix
de l'électro et forcément les
fournisseurs alternatifs n'ont pas pu
suivre et certains ont même dû congédier
leurs clients pour éviter l'hémorragie
et contenir la hausse des prix
l'exécutif a donc demandé à edf
d'augmenter les volumes céder à ce
concurrent 20 % de plus résultat edf qui
a déjà vendu sa production va devoir
acheter une partie de ces térawattheures
sur les marchés de gros à un prix
exorbitant pour le revendre deux trois
quatre voire cinq fois moins cher une
bouchée de pain tout ça pour sauver la
concurrence montant de la facture pour
edf 8 milliards d'euros quelle est cette
concurrence où on demande à un
producteur de subventionner ses rivaux
des niveaux qui ne produisent rien l'acr
eux ne contrôle pas l'utilisation qu'ils
font de cette production nucléaire ils
peuvent aller la vendre au prix fort sur
le marché et ramasser les profits sans
que personne ne leur disent rien pendant
ce temps là edf pei s'endette et
s'appauvrit tout ceci pour faire plaisir
à bruxelles car oui si on en est là
aujourd'hui c'est parce que la
commission européenne trouvait que le
monopole d'état sur l'électricité que
représentait edf était insupportable et
contrevenait au principe de la
concurrence libre et non faussée
concurrence qui doit en théorie servir
l'intérêt du consommateur alors voici lé
indices de prix de l'électricité depuis
1990 jusqu'en 2010 ça monte un peu mais
ça reste tolérable
depuis la création de la reine up +50 4%
en une décennie on ne peut pas vraiment
dire que le consommateur s'y retrouve
alors soyons précis cette augmentation
n'est pas dû qu'à la reine mais ce
dernier il ya bien sa part quant à la
concurrence non faussée subventionné par
edf à coups de mégawattheures garantie
prix bas par la loi on a fait mieux edf
quand elle se retrouve donc encore un
peu plus endettés et la chute du titre
va aggraver la situation autant d'argent
qui ne servira pas au développement du
renouvelable ni à l'entretien des
centrales ou des barrages d'ailleurs
l'europe aimerait bien aussi les mettre
en concurrence ces barrages enfin si
c'est dans l'intérêt du consommateur
européen